immediately after the trade much like he
did
when he was first signed in san antonio
where udoka had it
the eliza
[Applause]
rule back in
a little step up screen by looney
quick crossover
and looney with the layup
this is a good play by jordan poole gets
into the seams
game one he tried to do too much game
two he's made the adjustment give him
credit got scored 120 points
the golden state warriors much willing
to fall in love with steph curry's shot
making in the offense it's been their
defense that has taken over this time
jordan poole says let's go
golden state has a lot of time pool with
the ball
launches
oh
money
[Music]
[Applause]
flat out get it done
recognizing the clock twinline's down
knocks down the long ball good
old-fashioned game of
who
this presentation of the nba finals
continues after this spanish in a word
from our abc stations
steph curry in pick and roll action
they're going to be up
either switching from an up position
[Music]
or
where pierce used to make that cut they
would throw it over the top
nice wrinkle for smart against curry
cole drive and finish
[Music]
very picked up by tatum on the switch
throws back towards thompson's dream and
the finish
beautiful
[Applause]
bull keeps that dribble alive oh what a
fake from jordan poole and he banks it
in fan base that's the surgically
repaired knee that has been sore all
playoffs
how about that move
[Applause]
hooked away by wiggins
thompson ahead and wiggins throws it
down
hurry waiting for the screen pull goes
away
[Music]
pull off the bounce goes inside goes at
williams layup is good
[Applause]
tatum another pass deflected draymond
green got a piece of it
here comes paul season opening fires
connects
jordan pulled off the bench
eight points the golden state up five
timeout boston job off the deflection
to put them on their heels in transition
[Applause]
cool
[Applause]
nice little shake and bacon
[Applause]
smart really on the offensive glass
against curry right now oh beautiful
pass pull paul and peyton connect
[Music]
that's a quick pace here to start the
floor thompson no hesitation ties the
game play thompson from downtown
brown has had some excellent
postseason including a couple of
terrific games here in the finals as
wiggins floats it up and in
a little pin down they put two on the
ball
good pass
and finish by wiggins to me there's no
reason to put two on the ball in that
situation that same size that should
have been all
[Applause]
cool nice pull back nails the three
a willing pass that gets rid of the
basketball puts smart in position to
make the right read eight of his 15 here
in this third thompson tries to answer
and dodge
shot clock at three brown puts up the
three
off the mark rebound wiggins got three
seconds to get a shot off wiggins to
pull pull gets it off in time
[Applause]
they count it
using every possible second wiggins
wisely gets in a pool they're gonna look
at it
that's closer than it appeared in live
action but it it looks like he got it
off in time
[Music]
it's out of his fingertips right there
that's gonna count
what a wild sequence of events after a
choppy first half a thrilling third
quarter
but what a block from andrew wiggins
paul steps back backs it again paul
nails it that's 11 straight points
and the warriors are up five
wiggins drives on williams bank shot no
good draymond green tips it out to pull
and pull nails the three
to be on the offensive board he comes in
he wedges tatum out of the way
tips it back to pool that's a hard
derek white up and under can't get it to
go tops in the rebound
again golden state looking to push at
every opportunity threat the needle and
wiggins banks it in gorgeous speed from
thompson that he knocks in and then
tremendously fundamental
fast break by the warriors that leads to
a wiggins layup
knocking down shots but draymond green
is making plays all over the floor
another turnover
pushes finds wiggins wiggins throws it
down
and the celtics need another timeout
golden state scored 21 in a row get
double team get rid of the rock
excellent defense by the warriors off to
the races simple basketball in
transition
celebration by pool
[Applause]
smart looking to post a pool peyton
looking to help bad pass deflected by
thompson and another steal
wiggins inside the pain and peyton
throws it down
full on the drive gets inside reverse
layup is good sweet move from poole he's
got 15 points
brown
deflected momentarily
brown against curry drives spins into a
double team another turnover
into that crowd that you spoke about
jeff
here's thompson thompson to green banks
it in